welcome to this video a bit of a late
start here because I got an unexpected
phone call quite interesting game I'm
playing a grandmaster grievous from from
Greece to 568 this is a high rating so
he's um oops Jeff cause this one the
bogo let's see what he's doing against
the bogo night BTW too yeah I played d6
this kind of a strategical line the
castles line is my main choice and Jack
look what I'm writing but I tend to
forget those complicated line so I very
often in practice yep I prefer to to
play it in a bit simpler way like this
okay the support of the edge point is
quite often an interesting way to play
it makes sure that why it is not so um
so easily being able to put a for later
let's see should I plate c5 keeping it
closed or you know i can i'll do that
i'm not sure about this more taking is
not good for you might take with them
yeah okay okay so what do i know i think
this is just okay now because I control
deform maybe the combination of this
central point struct and the h-bond Musa
does not fit too well that that's
possible actually but then still I I
think that should be ok k Bishop g4 may
be irritating him
you cannot play Knight f3 because if I
hangs Bishop f3 Bishop e6 should be
quite helpful for me and they don't know
where the Queen actually should go maybe
to be three awesome here okay yeah
there's even Queen 85 here which I don't
think it's too bad let's do that this
position suffers a bit from this night
on d 2 which is simply not well placed
of course long term is got the bishops
that's always something and down maybe a
bit of bit of space d 6 is of course
slightly weak and i need to reroute this
night here on f6 this is not really well
placed ok this is must return anyway
night only five is just not well placed
ok I thought about us I really expected
Bishop a three but ok now i get night c
5 and 2 295 e6 in or at least 95 for the
time being
okay so he wants to bring the night or
in 925 yeah make sure i could have a
also cancelled long of course I need to
start with g60 rg6 was more precise now
he's got nine f5 okay okay so 96 or take
it now come on let's take it keep it
simple okay he what about f5 should i do
that not sure about the timing but I'd
like to get this activity in okay i want
to get gear go all the way to to e6 of
course with the king
and ok yeah maybe I'm just insecure them
that's possible
mmm yeah no f5 was mistimed and for oki
one was really strong check yeah I am
this is the problem
it takes on d fone iron and needed to
take with the pawn time morning yeah
this was okay at the start but then he
outplayed me really f5 was really bad if
I don't do f5 I think this is
sufficiently solid maybe it's it's a
it's slightly passive
I only only try I mean 43 seconds not
not one hundred percent sure about the
position actually is this so bad why do
I get some sort of counter play looks it
to us some counterplay check
you can't just take it I just blended
this he can take cookie too yeah black
resigns yeah I thought maybe he i am
even have something on the computer
gives it is equal check it's not really
surprised but because of rooks e5 which
is quite difficult for a human with 40
or 30 seconds that's a strong
intermediate move of course here check
where this was ok this was just
happening by coincidence I was of course
I'm quite outplayed and FF 5s boss is
probably bad I mean I need to time this
much much better this is this type of
play I mean it's clear that i'm somewhat
worse but it's it shouldn't be that
terrible happened after f5 it got
terrible of course one problem is of
this structure that he got in this
Bishop h3 stuff
yeah yeah it's not a very attractive
position they can play this you can
always get in bishop age 3 which is
really the key to the position this
whole thing is based on the assumption
that white has a bad piece on g2 and
black can't defend his weakness on d6
but if he gets in Bishop h3 on which you
will do here then this is not really am
really helping me so why does some is
better that's this probably means that
Queen 85 was not a good news I don't
think that this can be any great for
white I mean I can I can play like that
for example yeah for what it's worth the
computer gives me an advantage here but
at least its playable it's it's simply I
don't have any any better structural
piece I mean if you compare this for
example the structure to the kalashnikov
Sicilian which is the same structure see
poem exchange for d pony for in c4 then
this is a pretty good version of that
because I don't have this dark square
Bishop anymore and whites pieces are
simply somewhat cluttered something like
that is what the computer is giving with
about body quality yeah the point is
what I want to do is I always want to go
get tonight to 24 which I manage here so
Queen f5 was probably nonsense this is
nonsense it loses too much time also
besides the fact of course that here you
had Bishop e3 which I appointed I wasn't
doing the game which is even stronger
somehow I didn't do that but what he did
was perfectly okay it was this kind of
snow play that is hard to counter how I
need to need to do it without f5 but
this is this is really really not
comfortable so the the key was that I
shouldn't
play em play the screen a 5 mph but go
to 97 now this is this is pretty
comfortable all right actually okay
interesting thanks for watching